okay Monarch Legacy of Monsters has
premiered shall we watch it let's
welcome to SRE your SciFi TV and mve a
[Music]
channel
the world is on
fire monor was there in San
Francisco so I am going to watch this
and I'm going to pause and I'm going to
tell you what I think as we go along my
first instinct Apple has spent some
money on this apple plus do tend to go
for quality over quantity this is what
we've said many times on this channel we
we like apple plus on here we made not
like the business practices of Apple
generally speaking but apple plus we
like so I'm going to say first of all
they've spent some decent money on this
and my first two Instincts by the will
there will be minor spoilers ahead if
you haven't seen it so you know be
warned I love John Goodman he's amazing
and I don't like spiders I have
Arachnophobia the first two minutes of
this episode have made the hairs on the
back of my neck
go I like him was working for them this
stuff wasn't as safe who are they what's
Monarch I do like a funky little bit in
the opening sequence actually where if
you don't know already Kurt Russell
plays um a character in the present day
but his son Wyatt plays the same
character in um an early period in like
the 50s or something so where they've
got the thing at the and Kurt Russell
and white and they just sort of change
the letters around so that it you know
like it merges together sort thing I
quite like that I love actually that
they've got the son to to play him as an
earlier character as well because he
does look a lot like Kurt Russell when
he was younger which is weird I mean
genetics and all that it's his son so
yeah um I love that I think it's really
clever and a nice little no to it and
yeah I love in the opening sequence as
well by the way quite good very I have
the feel of the movies as well to it so
which is a good
thing this is the world we live in
monsters are an inescapable
reality now this series was written and
developed by Chris black now that might
be a name that you know because he has
worked on loads of really very cool
projects over the years he actually
worked on Ugly Betty something I never
watched and S reference a recent movie
which I've never watched but he did
produce and write sliders which I did
watch Zena Warrior Princess which I
watched and loved like most of us we
shouldn't have liked that show so much
by the way guys but we did and he did a
show called Reaper which was something
actually that um I adored it was a very
funny show it it didn't get the credit
it deserved to be
fair um and it didn't it don't I think
last a season but it was basically about
Satan had picked the next Satan and he
was but he didn't want to do it um but
yeah it was a great show and it was
really
underappreciated monsters and Monarch
have taken everything from
me no
more in the first couple of minutes of
the episode there's loads of Godzilla
references and there's a reference to
the attack on San Francisco and things
like that it was done by CGI apparently
which is something people would do this
good country but I love how in Japan
they've got these missile defense
systems and drones and things and loads
of signs in the background one's a big
Godzilla picture with like a do not
cross sign over the top is brilliant so
yeah lots of Godzilla references in the
first couple of minutes of this
episode one of the characters Le is a
dumbass they've just found a bunch of
alien looking eggs that are definitely
monsters that are definitely going to
hatch and are definitely going to try to
eat these people and one of the
character Lee wants to go down and get a
sample of the genetic material cuz that
can never go wrong have none of these
people ever seen a monster or an A
sci-fi movie well yes because Kurt
Russell's son has seen a Sci-Fi or
Monster movie and he does not want to go
because he knows they're going to try to
eat them at least one person in this
series has some common
sense
yep she got eaten by
cockroaches massive
cockroaches so that's the first episode
of monik the second episode is available
as well I'm can't watch it right now
because I have to go and do my proper
job but what did I think Apple really
have pulled out all the stops of this
it's a very nicely done show uh the
special effect
are virtually Cinema quality the one
time we see goia goia um looks straight
out the movie from 2014 it's it's it's
absolutely perfect to be honest um this
the writing is topnotch Chris black has
done it again the acting Top Notch we
haven't seen Kurt Russell yet I want to
see Kurt Russell but he will appear at
some point um there's lots going on it
ties in with the movie and the movies
really really well well and we've
already seen Kong as well um I think
this is really going to give us um a a
much better picture that fills in a lot
of the gaps from the movies movies that
honestly are not normally
MTI Godzilla King Kong they're not
normally my thing but those films have
been really really good um they've
quietly built a really really nice
franchise and and this series really is
going to add an awful lot of depth to
that franchise so what is my overall
opinion of Monarch rise of the monsters
it's excellent um to be honest apple
plus I just knocked it out the park once
again I'm really looking forward to
watching the next episode but sadly for
now I have to go and do my real work but
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
don't forget to leave a comment what did
you you think of this series and is this
the sort of show that you would actually
subscribe to apple plus 4 in my opinion
you most definitely
should but only for a month binge it and
then go watch something else for a
couple of months because there's not
enough on Apple Plus really to be like a
constant subscriber a month go watch
something else for a
bit but I'd love to know what you think
so please get into the comments um
please go over to patreon.com citrek for
more and you get to see most of our
videos premere there first also can get
to
c.co where we do articles based on a lot
of our videos um we Tred to add a little
bit more information for you to digest
right I better get back to it as always
though please stay safe and I'll see you
next
[Music]
time